attendez
c'est aussi dire vend ses appareils puis
aujourd'hui facilité qui s'est alors
senti assez gentil et mardi que sont
razi je pourrais servir au bout les
patients peuvent ainsi pioneer non moi
je ne sais pas egidio pas tiens où je
croise souvent dit je pense que si je le
redis by ap les choix
poutine ouanna n'a rien si ouali way and
only moi je suis tout aussi j'ai pas dis
je le dis je prends hop je dis et je
bossais s'est ainsi interrogé par
agences intesa c'est du bonbon
je vais à tige en bambou en s'immergeant
laisser henry et qu'on leur ait dit 4h10
échanges de feu et quand je dis on sent
déjà bon
s'il vous plaît alors
comme ancien en annonçant récemment
changé
non non non ça n'existe pas avec moi là
et a pris deux fautes et je suis riche
me dis et je redis j'étais petit je me
suis couché
si je dis aux voitures l'enjeu en est
j'y étais allé non s'il vous plaît
mieux l'ancien et tu allais aller oui
pas de problème
la volonté j'entends dire voici la di ob
affronteront bons et loyaux services
on dit attention à dire changé et l'on
sait on si on n'y peut rien
et aujourd'hui j'ai aussi non scipion
jeudi pour ce deal radio voit son mari
foncier motors annonce mardi
et avoue je sais pas si c'est pas
inquiet c'est aujourd'hui je prends à
londres a dit je m'excuse c'est moi qui
parle vallée rouge était hissé à part de
passer par leur entité enfin non pas
fini je suis parti je me suis dit voilà
dix rouge
aa je me suis dit la carte verte souple
et sa carte verte mais parce que je n'ai
pas dit je n'ai pas eu facile à faire
vite
alors là moi aussi je suis pas je me
suis ce qui se passe merci je vais pas
sur la carte via cela dit j'ai pas aussi
bien que nous venons ici je suis rouge
veillera
mais au moins j'ai bousillé le service
de dieu dont je sens si je dois aussi à
la carte verte jeudi rougemont
petit mais aussi que tu parles moi si je
pas réellement passé et puis ce n'est
pas une oie dit c'est à dire je pense
aussi à giscard d'estaing et alors c'est
que vous citez là aussi rouge vert je
veux dire jusqu'à n'essayait jongle tout
le monde pense lui un gentil j'en serais
si je mens sur a10 et puis j'ai dit au
revoir et puis je suis parti